yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is a I wanna blitz arena I'm going
to go for the 5 minute games yeah I
haven't done the video yesterday seems
my rating is going down all the time
this is kind of a joke this raining
anyway M I'm playing the 5 minute
gentlemen
I haven't done a video yesterday
unfortunately I couldn't do it I wanted
to do it in the evening but somehow I
didn't feel all that well so I decided
it's not a good idea to do a video I'm
better now just somehow I didn't I'm the
the food somehow didn't agree with me
anyway so I'm ok now
and I'm going to play this tournament
this is the first game against real
kochu and we have a scotch for nights
opening yep very sounded solid opening
let's see what real is up to I'm just
going to develop my pieces a rook will
come - do you wanna know guess yeah and
we have the straight very very often in
this opening I think hmmm I'm going to
go to do this always unsure if I should
go to a 42
okay so I think I don't think I do this
just stay flexible okay it seems
unlikely that I can play before him
maybe I should have done this
differently but okay I can't take now
here and then see ya now before is
actually a moose is it a good one I
don't know I really don't know I'm not
so accustomed yet to those positions and
he's taking it interesting name enough
so be five I think I got him if he goes
a five then B five will give me a person
once I have 94 because of the bishop
takes h7 tactic I'm controlling the
center moment he can play d4 I'm not
sure about this move it could be a good
decision or it could be wrong okay I
think I'm putting this here it looks
correct and I have some additional ideas
like Knight f5 one ib5 now it looks
looks fine yeah I think white is
slightly for choice him rooks III
there's again bishop h7
I wonder if Bishop f5 is an idea in such
a position I don't know it definitely
would be good if he takes it like Bishop
f5 Bishop takes Knight xa5 but black
will probably not take ever yeah
interesting I think I go [ __ ] five give
me let's create the passer
okay so 96 it's an interesting question
if this is doing any good or not yeah I
also have to watch out for loops III for
sure so do I just move the bishop that
would be easiest I don't know where
though something there is potentially
Rupe c4 this is something after take
into account a system of maybe intending
knight c6 it covers the night and it has
a look at these six they have many also
knight c6 queenie for could be an idea
yeah this is quite comfortable for white
but not not so easy
Brooks III know he goes back I could
definitely just take on his six which is
better for white for sure okay so look
to c3 just stroke and one is he
threatening anything Luke a3 maybe but
it's also not a big deal I can always
move the knight yeah now move the knight
even taking is an option hmm but I don't
really have a good good follow up
yeah 96 was my original intention here
hmm maybe it is just right to trade this
book this is the only active piece that
he's got my group gave one but that
would blunder quite horribly so what's
to do Bishop f5 now would actually
threaten his sex this is an idea you
know he's got SAP back rank issues as
well like if he takes it Queen takes I'm
threatening Queen d7 yeah that's not bad
what if he takes a four I can take twice
only six threatening would I have six
yeah and it's going to be tricky for
black maybe he's got something else you
know like 94 so I can just move move the
Queen he I'm just threatening I think to
take on f6 and I threaten rupee eight
him that's the bigger threat rupee 898
Queen f8 curtains
one some cases again we'll get six yeah
I still can check on the aid not sure if
that wins there is night no 95 blunder
stuff yeah let's do it
I'm not I don't have tons of time and I
couldn't quite see a defense edge of
this and he also couldn't so threaten
those two squares unfortunately he's got
this one very unfortunate but okay the
Queen cannot move and I've gotten myself
into a pin here which is entirely
unnecessary really shouldn't that I
should have played really better I mean
not 97 I was a stupid move
yeah that's again the sailfin so let's
see I should
window window porn and again it's a self
in not a big problem okay so it took a
long time but I won the game mmm wasn't
that some way to get okay I got the
standings here still somewhat behind
peace um well slowly take three games
set amazing I came I don't know if I
should bezerk I didn't want to stress
myself out early in the morning so let's
play just normal stuff just try to play
some good games I'm not I mean I want to
win the tournament just don't get me
wrong but yeah this is a line that I
actually had discarded but it's it's
like a bad habit yeah somehow I still
have to do it once in a while
the good thing about this Chi Goren line
is I can play a million moves quickly
and I have a soft spot for for this
somehow I mean it's it's generally okay
to play this against a weaker opposition
because I usually don't understand the
maneuvering game but it's not an opening
I would recommend it to play regularly
against good players
mm-hmm glide should never take one g7
so I've got this defensive setup ready
and let's see if I can create everything
here that's not too terrible because you
have some challenges on the kingside
this book at least them white can make
mistakes this is what happens quite
frequently that they don't play this
this very well yeah I think I'm
basically okay him this has to go to f8
and now I need to see that I can
activate unite h5 would be good to get
in tries to trade this okay and he
prevents made h5 okay Bishop h4 could be
irritating yeah he's playing this quite
well actually
what is playing this very well actually
yeah how can you win this game after the
Queen trade probably noti'm but again
why did it a good good job yeah very
good job it's how can I possibly win
this game is there a way to do it I mean
I have to be aware that he might be able
to sacrifice him this is looking like he
has this intention even like take on c5
or t25 this is possible when I pieces
here are somewhat off I don't know where
he's going to go when's he going here
with this uh-huh okay now I can go here
right am i blundering something I don't
see it I think I can just take it for an
extra
yeah I think he has screwed up I just
get you for not much
came just back on yeah probably back
it's still not an automatic win
absolutely not
after the Knights traded and he puts the
King on e4 can probably not win and need
to trade bishops if possible or maybe
get get this Bishop around to g7 and
then take this and then play Knight
against the bishop even that is not an
easy women g5 is interesting now but I
don't think he can't wrap my membership
yeah I saw this but I think he cannot
trap it that being said it's not quite
clear what I'm doing now let's go here
how can i play this my knight can do
wire age five
maybe I can I can I can work with the
sacrifice yeah I can go age six years
instead of move my cheek cheeks it
should work
he doesn't have h for you know I can
take it
okay so do I do I grab it all go age
five I think I should think Bishop takes
and now all of a sudden I recognize that
there is Bishop d8 just around the
corner which is more than a problem it
is a huge problem big vacation yeah of
course going to d8 can never be right
you know the other thing is just a draw
aha terrible terrible
I lose the Jeep on that's going to be a
real real issue if I go 97 he can go
night eh which is an idea anyway
maybe I have to maybe I have to use some
yeah I was thinking Bishop f4 maybe hmm
if he takes a couple of times I can take
on c4 at the end and promote the pawn
and it can be really objectively working
97 is also crap
I'm totally miss playing this stuff oh
my god okay let's go into trick mode
she's not even falling for anything
don't understand this game I don't
understand how this works I'm okay all
of a sudden out play means its position
after playing so badly at the beginning
I have no idea anyway so I lost this one
so to us yeah I have to work now you
just blundered upon blundered you for
for absolutely zilch
yeah I didn't play well afterwards but
still anyway so what's going on here
very strange opening
yeah wacky eloquent defense with Knight
to f4 really really strange my
development is fine something like 95 I
probably have to do this laughter 97
it's not clear that this needs much and
is the most natural move
Jim I thought I should try to open the
position early because of my leading
development so steep this was a double
attack now on the bishop and the Queen
yeah I think I should win stuff and I
have to keep in mind that I'm berserk
Inge why why am I not getting really
getting lower and lower with the rating
I don't do well in those tournaments but
still I mean there are people on the
side with blitz riding with blitz
ratings of 2900 and they're not better
than than I am rather on the contrary
okay so let's think about this game only
this is time two nights up two nights
okay so he resigned
so maybe I'm getting getting back into
the upper half of this
maybe I should stop to play that she go
run I mean I said okay I was completely
winning probably so it wasn't really due
to the opening yeah now I've got black
in the Scotch for Knights oh this is not
a good oh good move at all
but Yahoo bar completely forgotten how
this is played
visually for
Wow I don't remember though how can it
just cancel if you should have formed
probably just f6
yeah he has to take more lesson tonight
takes
Wow
isn't this just losing five
and I just just lose the five
yeah I'm I'm greedy don't want to play
for when you had another piece and we
get another it's wrong but with a piece
on top of the pawn okay so I'm a pizza
and I have an attack with the you should
have five coming okay I'm still on the
second page what are the first what 17
points
how can you play seven games I have
played four okay like berserk every move
and win quickly yeah I had a the first
the first two games they took ages and
even lost one of them exactly the same
opening
not sure if this is exactly the correct
move water but I think this is a good
line against the black setup 97 probably
on f5 ok I'm going to support this maybe
it could have taken an f3 hmm much very
much possible okay so
you should age five I assume I don't I
don't have a good square for the night
maybe I have to go back to e1 I'm not
quite sure what he is thinking about I'm
ready for night b5 and some cases and it
doesn't do much not not very happy with
this pollution
okay this helped I think it's just a
double check a seven and d6
yeah that should be quite good for me I
don't think he has a good move now and
it's not just a lot of porn a seven is
wendy6 he cannot afford to lose at all
and a seven is probably also quite
important keeping keeping things
together on the queenside
yeah here c5 is an idea and then push
these six yeah I think I think I will
just take now make sure that the pawns
cannot move that quickly
46 no actually there's also Queen to c4
pawn takes Queen C 4kd 60s Queen to f7
which is good
doesn't help okay let's play this then I
didn't live on b7 hmm I would really
would have liked to have the night
already on the freezer there are some
coordination issues him move like Queen
to b3 or even this one
hmm
it is the reason why my reading sucks
I'm playing I'm playing badly simply I
mean I'm screwing this up yeah it was a
fantastic position it was just
completely winning position after taking
a seven and then I come I played some
really really weird ideas that that
didn't work if I was also weird move
probably I'm overlooking stuff but I
don't think so actually
ninety seven is a threat now
that is so I can beat him
okay so there's queen of Freud's I have
g3
look a one maybe this is an idea that
could be an idea be to Palmas some or
bad
okay I have to play a move Knight takes
d4 also was good but I think he's just
panicking now okay
I was tough I jumped to third place but
the first place is really really wild 22
and his played like double the games
with nine games it's crazy
he's probably be working and then like
play like like possessed it's almost
impossible to catch nine points
it's bottle especially if I if you don't
get a game how can they play so many
things and maybe those those openings
those long openings long openings is
really weird English those opening lines
that lead to longer games they are
probably not helping I know it says no
move come on well that's good really b5
that's funny
okay so I'm happy with this of course
having a nice position so early let wind
stuff right with default the default
Bishop f6 Queen takes I win the rook in
the corner
or something else okay I have to trade
Queens but I'm a woke up
am I not yeah look for two points he
will still continue and this is what
makes it a bit of a pain because you
don't win super quickly I mean it's a
look but it will still take some moves
yeah like if he resigns now that would
be a fantastic situation winning a game
really really quickly but but he won't
put it on a five the bishop maybe night
around 25 okay oh that's nice she's
opening up the position for me it's
really helpful
yeah just get rid of this this this
piece can just take c6 neck smooth and
makes it a bit easier
and yeah this is the thing you need to
build a little bit of luck and that
people simply resign such a position and
then you can catch up but not if they
just play on in a hopeless position
forever
we didn't get another pawn but
you know whatever can do probably I can
cannot do anything that makes him resign
the game and I have a minute Jim
you know isn't a checkmating net almost
almost
can you want to continue for a moment
okay yeah could have resigned like four
minutes ago and then it's a different
story but this way no chance I mean okay
I can just avoid your losses the dirty
game and not be on third place this way
but still you need this bit of luck I
mean this guy never can play like ten
games without people resigning somewhat
early it's also funny that jackie has
lost three games but okay that's the
guys that I'm trailing that's good so I
can if I win this I have shown just you
can't job taking money for a bit of a
strange decision okay wait it's playable
of course maybe this is an idea g4s
quindi for him
hmm
okay and it was a bit long
it's not for too long
okay let's let's try something I mean
I'm not sure that this is so good but
given the tournament situation in the
time situation maybe I should try
something more drastic it doesn't seem
to care or what I'm doing okay this guy
is on second place hmm okay yeah well
it's my own fault
that I'm not leading the tournament but
anyway so g7 okay and he resigns so five
points behind orokin I mean if they pair
me against him I can still win this I
get five points for a win against him it
would be nice but he just has started
the game so buddy so okay let's see he
let's say he loses this and I win I mean
okay but I have to get him I have to get
a game first and it doesn't seem like I
get one
okay actually pretty good opponent
anyway okay we need to bring out the big
guns really that is possible I don't
think this is good I mean probably play
aboard probably not really a good
opening so let's see if he goes Queen
h5g six takes
yeah okay yeah I'm just better but the
question is can you can you do much with
this in the time the time given
mmm-hmm I didn't play with more water
him castling long quickly would have
been fantastic but I couldn't get it in
and now he has all sorts of discoveries
unknown I have seven oh come on
I'm pretty playing like an idiot here
and he doesn't do it oh my god okay well
this is this is nice yeah no I'm just
just in good shape unless he has some
technique with the night doesn't even
try
yeah Bishop h4 stuff always a check now
doesn't it's not that though let's do it
and f3
so they made that I'm not seeing it
would be embarrassing maybe this is this
is good enough I think
threatening one see to this was also a
threat but the a key couldn't do
anything anymore
okay so I'm winning this one maybe yeah
he does so yeah but orokin has won his
game and I had a look at what she was
losing like immediately and he's losing
again here in the position I can see it
here on the screen so if I win I don't
know I need to get the game and win in
six minutes probably difficult that will
be difficult
hmm yeah yeah you cannot afford to lose
the game it seems and I don't get how
would this guy gets in like 12 games I
have eight I mean eight and twelve it's
pretty pretty crazy
why do you check with the Queen that's
good news of course maybe I have some
chances to win really quickly let's do
it
something something bonkers I have to be
very quick iam
I don't want to take c6 that is just
slow h5 very quickly it's almost a pre
move so let's take this and I'm just
playing this now don't looking for I
mean okay he takes I'm checkmating him
and 93 isn't even a check this is quite
important yeah so so I'm I'm equal now
and he has lost already just started the
game so I don't know I mean am i had if
I have the lower game count or I'm not
sure what to rule is them that he plays
against someone they both deserved and I
don't get a game yeah I don't know I'm
sure about my screen estate yeah you can
see almost the position here maybe white
is better here in this game but nothing
special gana the sky what did he do what
it was that was the that that did we had
pneumonia I can do this again I don't
think he will play the same line again
he will I don't get it but he had a
completely crap position
okay when this quite obviously is bad
for white and I don't quite know why he
would repeat it but he does I'm playing
a bit differently now
focusing on a quick castling yeah the
problem is that this is the system quite
clearly nothing for white but it's also
not something I can win quickly hmm I'm
just better here with the then with the
bishop and the better structure but you
need more than two minutes something to
win c5 now I can try to be like super
quick but you would have to win an
ending here it's the problem cannot just
checkmate him also and just need to
enter game that doesn't that won't work
I mean okay if it rates everything down
now what is this I have no drugs I don't
have loops eh that was a weird idea
somehow I was thinking I take and play
rook c8 which is not on what we had idea
a-five helps ya rupee one I have to make
some awkward move one minute 15 that
will very likely not be possible b-pawn
is pretty strong but why is he not
stopping it
I mean okay whoopsy monopod
let's see how to do this I had 25
seconds
okay I'm not winning this in 25 seconds
that's not happening and probably the
other guy has won his game who
miraculously but Tama if he gets to 13
games I mean he probably has has is it
deserved winners somehow I don't know
how you do it really gets a bit too bit
crazy
yeah and it's over I'd say I don't think
this is even I don't think this is even
counted for raiding why is he continuing
this I mean you're just you're just
losing here in this position probably
what I don't get it
I mean offered to draw in a winning
position just because I think it it
doesn't matter at which he declined yeah
it actually did count for a surprising
so probably with the same game count
with the same points he lost the final
game how can you get 5 I don't get this
like 5 this is 13 game so I think he's
got 13 games
I managed 9 yeah okay no not a great
tournament they had some bad moments
they have it summer I wanted at the end
yeah I hope you enjoyed it maybe I will
make a additional video today later it
depends on what I'm going to do today
which is not quite clear okay guys
thanks for watching